si google stars es para ti 4 se espera
agüero se espera que los escrutinios se
leen en aproximadamente cuatro días para
el sábado 20 de febrero pero debe
comentarte que se ha convocado una
movilización en nacional una gran marcha
por la vida así lo han denominado los
grupos indígenas que partieron el día de
hoy desde el sur del país e irán
atravesando distintas provincias del
país para acercarse y concentrarse
específicamente acá a mis espaldas en
las inmediaciones del consejo nacional
electoral donde cada día se refuerza un
operativo de seguridad el candidato ya q
pérez y las organizaciones indígenas han
convocado a esta gran marcha y han dicho
que debe ser una marcha pacífica han
resaltado específicamente el coordinador
nacional del movimiento pachakutik y
marlon santi aseguró que es una marcha
pacífica y no aceptarán personas
infiltradas esto antes algunas denuncias
que ha presentado el día de hoy que
según ellos tienen conocimiento que las
marchas están siendo infiltradas para
provocar violencia a cualquier persona
que pretende infiltrar se se le aplicará
la ley indígena paralelamente también el
candidato ya q pérez ha presentado un
rollo
y distintos recursos administrativos y
legales en las asignaciones del consejo
nacional electoral donde nos encontramos
nosotros en este momento han formalizado
el pedido de suspensión de los
escrutinios para el que se detenga y se
abra inclusive este escrutinio electoral
de igual forma pide en la institución de
los consejeros igual forma se espera que
llegue acá en seis días aproximadamente
y los conteos para el próximo 20 de
febrero